[Music]
for
dear father I'm sure you know by now I
decided to leave Harvard
travel
West I hope to find a stronger
purpose and more meaning in my
life expand my understanding of the
world Beyond
Boston it's something that I need to
do you may not understand
this
but I hope you can accept
it I'll be back before
winter with
love
William
[Applause]
all
two bits extra if you want water brought
up you be here
long not sure
sir do you know where I can find a JD
McDonald you here for business no sir
well if you follow the road to end of
town you'll see a
Sha
that is
impressive that ain't
nothing better off chopping
w
a these
ain't says who Market that's
who if you want to be a hid man you have
to go do it yourself now go on and kill
some more buff someone else
will me I'm is it's
worth Judy
Maloney my loone I know everybody said
Robert C Hansen and Marshall Solomon
s sir come back
tomorrow then my name is William Andrews
sir I reckon you don't remember me huh
if IID remembered you I'd have said
something when you first came in
my my father is Edward Andrews sir he is
the Minister of the Unitarian Church in
Boston we took you in about 14 years ago
you come out looking for work here I I I
I saved your letters all of
them my father spoke of you
often I wasn't anyone for him to speak
of I think he admired you because you
were the only man he knew who came out
here and made a life for
himself that's right
that's
right I did 400,000 Buffalo hides last
year and it's just a start I send out
parties they bring in the hides I plan
on doing my own cure and intant right
here do it all
myself your father's a Harvard Man
shouldn't you be in school I I went but
I'm just not interested in that kind of
education you want a job God knows I
can't keep up I'm already two months
behind I didn't come out of here for
that I'm I
want well what is it boy spit it out
already I would like to see as much of
the country as I
can get to know it uh maybe you could
send me out with one of your hunting
parties
sir
boy I won't be responsible you start
going out with those men it'll ruin you
it'll get in you like Buffalo lice
you'll be rotten from the inside I'm
sorry to bothered you Mr
McDonald you got it all figured out no
sir I I don't have anything figured
out hell was I talking
[Music]
about
call be said always
[Music]
forgive
H excuse me sir um I believe uh I saw
you earlier today what can I do for
you I would like to
go on a hunt
sir a't no tours around here
not a
tour a hunt I can be helpful and
um
understand around the camp I'm a rather
quick study
uh this's Charlie H he's my C
man Mr
there don't mind Charlie son it's just
his idea of fun have a seat
will get the
drinks hi how do you
do why don't you tie up with one of
McDonald's
parties Mr McDonald and I don't see it
the same way McDonald's a crook we do
the work he takes all the
money I work for myself or I don't
work M don't work for
nobody things are changing around
here used to be you could get a thousand
head in just a couple of weeks of
hunt now the herds have
scattered it's getting hard to make a
real
kill but there are still places that
they can be
found
that